can you just clarify just fascinating uh
the shape of things so the shape of the
Milky Ways of the observable stuff is
mostly
flat and then you said Dark Matter tends
to be spherical but a subset of that
might be a flat disc so you want to hear
about the shape of things yeah yes
please so structure formed early on and
now our structure that we live in is so
we know about the Milky Way galaxy so
the Milky Way galaxy has the disc you
can see in a dry dark place that's where
stars and light is but you can also
measure in some ways the dark matter and
we believe that dark matter is more or
less spherically
distributed um and like we said there's
a lot of it not necessarily in the dis
but just because it's a sphere there's a
lot of it sitting there and and the
reason it doesn't collapse as far as we
know is that it doesn't really it can't
radiate the same way so because it can
radiate ordinary matter collapses and
it's actually because of conservation of
angular momentum it be it stays the dis
and it doesn't just collapse to the
center so our suggestion was that maybe
there are some components of dark matter
that also radiate like I said that's far
from proven people have looked for a
discs they see some evidence of some
discs of certain densities but I see
these are all questions that are worth
asking basically if we can figure it out
from existing measurements why not try
Okay so there's not all Dark Matters
made the same this well that's a
possibility we actually don't know what
dark matter is in the first place we
don't know what most of it is we don't
know what a fraction is I mean it's hard
to measure why is it hard to measure for
exactly the reason you said earlier we
don't see it so we want to think of
possibilities for what it can be if
especially if those give rise to some of
observational consequences I mean it's
it's a tough game because it's not
something that's just there for the
taking you have to think about what it
could be and how you might find it and
the way you detect it is gravitational
effects on things we can see that would
be the way you detect the type of Dark
Matter I've been talking about people
have suggestions for other forms of dark
matter they could be particles called
axons they could be other types of
particles and then there are different
ways of detecting it I mean the most
popular candidate for Dark Matter
probably until pretty recently because
they haven't found it is something
called wimps weekly interacting mass of
particles um particles that have mass
about the same as the higs boson Mass um
and it turns out then you would get
about the right density of dark matter
but then people really like that of
course because it is connected to the
standard Mar the particles that we know
about and if it's connected to that we
have a better chance of actually seeing
it fortunately or unfortunately it's
also a better chance that you can rule
it out because you can look for it and
so far no one has found it we're still
looking for it is that one of the hopes
of the large hydron collider that was
originally one of the hopes of large
hydron collider I'd say at this point it
would be very unlikely given what
they've already accomplished um but
there are these um underground detectors
Xenon detectors that look for Dark
Matter coming in and they they are going
to try to achieve a much stronger bound
than it exists today just uh take that
tangent Looking Back Now what's the
biggest to you
Insight uh to humanity that the LHC has
been able to provide it's interesting
it's both um a major victory um the higs
bosone was proposed 50 years ago and it
was discovered the higs mechanism seemed
to be the only way to explain elementary
particle masses and it was right so on
the one hand it was a major victory on
the other hand I've been in physics long
enough to know it was also a cautionary
Tale in some sense because um at the
time I started in physics we had some
proposed something in the United States
called the superc conducting super
collider a lot of physicists I'll say
particularly in Europe but I'd say a lot
of physicists were sanguin that the
large hyron collider would have the
energy reach necessary to discover what
underlies the standard model we don't
want to just discover the standard model
we want to know what the next step is
and I think here um people were more
cautious about that they wanted to have
a more comprehensive search that could
get to higher energies more events so
that we could
you know we can really more definitively
rule it out but in that case many people
thought they knew what would be there it
happened to be a theory called super
symetry so a lot of physicists thought
it would be super symmetry I mean it's
one of the many factors I think that
went into the fact that the large hron
collider became the only machine in town
and um the superc conducting super
collider would have just been a much if
it really had achieved what it was
supposed to would have been a much more
robust test of of the space so so I'd
say for Humanity it's both a attribute
to the ability of Discovery and the
ability of really believing in things so
that you have the confidence to go look
for them but it's also a cautionary tail
that you don't want to you know assume
things before they've been actually
found so you want to do things in you
know you you want to believe in your
theories but you also want to question
them at the same time in ways that
you're more likely to discover the truth
but it's also an illustration of grand
engineering efforts that Humanity can
take on and maybe a lesson that
you could go even bigger um I'm really
glad you said that though too because
that that's absolutely true I mean it's
it really is an impressive it's it's
impressive in so many ways it's
impressive technologically it's
impressive in engineering level it's
also impressive that so many countries
worked together um to to do this it
wasn't just one country and how it was
it was also impressive in that it was a
long-term project that people committed
to and made it happen so
it is a demonstration that when people
set their minds to things and they
commit to it that they can do something
amazing but also in the United States uh
maybe a lesson that bureaucracy can slow
things down to bureaucracy and and
politics politics and economics many
many things can make them faster and
make them slower so science is the way
to make progress politics is the way to
slow that progress down and here we are
well I don't want to over say that
because without Politics the you know
the L would happen either so um but you
need broccoli
um but sometimes I do think I mean
you're not asking this question but
sometimes I do think when I you know
think about some of these conflicts you
know sometimes it's just good to have a
project that people work on together and
there were some efforts to do that with
in science too to have Palestinians and
Israelis work together project called
Sesame um I think it's not a bad idea
when you can do that um when you can get
you
know sort of for forget the politics and
just focus on some particular project
sometimes that can work some kind of
forcing function some kind of deadline
that gets people to sit in a room
together and you're working on a thing
but as part of that you realize the
common Humanity that you all have the
same concerns the same hopes the same
fears the same that we're all human and
that's an accidental side effect of
working together on a thing I that's
absolutely true and it's one of the
reasons CERN was formed actually it was
post World War II and lot of European
physicists had actually left Europe and
they wanted to see Europeans work
together and sort of rebuild and and it
worked I mean they they did and it's
true and I often think that that you
know one of the major problems is we
just don't meet enough people so that
everyone think seems when they seem like
the other it's more easy to forget their
Humanity so I think it it is important
to have these
connections